what's up guys we're dude perfect
welcome to Dallas Stars edition well we
got our good buddies Tyler Seguin and
Jamie been Detroiters
this is the blue line straight
this is like goalies were mad
yeah
man this is the 6 4 double smash here we
go
Jason fiction that is bloody
spin
I'll go
welcome to another exclusive dude
perfect interviews it's going to be a
little bit competition based I've
noticed that you guys are a little bit
into the ink game you know what I'm
saying
one minute Ashley tat competition here's
my interests pumping fishing all sports
Jesus and candy go Tyler's doing a lot
of giggling over here not a lot of
drawing - Wow okay
it's time for me to take the plunge
okay we're good all right
oh we got some hockey sticks because
we're hockey player of course I charge a
little crotch and then he's doing a
little fishing
oh Jesus Tyler why don't you take us
through what we got on this this is a
corn dog okay
Oh for the first competition I'm gonna
have to go with Jamie Ben guy this is
called lighting the match here we go
day two filming with chubs and sags
Tyler and Jamie we just want to fit in
with the boys okay so it's time for us
to unveil what weird we have good to go
bro my favorite here is the eat more
chicken slogan time to shoot a little
ski talk to staff
I
welcome to the classic game of pinata
Buster's who could spill the most candy
the winner is welcome to a little
segment called can you score with this
I'm gonna go pretty easy on them but I'm
gonna also let them know who's boss in
the process and enlarge rubber ducky I
don't wanna get cuckoo
Chason fiction that
when you
I'm gonna give
guys
you know you've got the fiscal aspect of
the game and you've got the mental
aspect it again oh my god your socks and
sandals combo that's not what you guys
do have very game is sit around in your
socks and say that's a perfectly good
glazed doughnut
again coca-cola a feeling like a
doughnut
the first one to smile nose is one two
three
on your mark get set go
Jaime min is the winner of the
competition
yes yes how does that feel
because amazing I just and boy Tyler
Jamie could help me do the otter Jason
fiction
much
Oh
free gym
ah
what's up guys thanks for watching if
you want to get tickets to one of this
year's games go to Dallas Stars com
gonna play your iPhone game click over
in this corner you'll see our last video
click over in this corner hey make sure
you guys follow Jamie and Tyler on
social media to close some links down
here on top of them for you to click on
Twitter and Instagram by the way hey
reading with our signature sign-off boys
about it